plus léger approche plus j'ai
l'impression qu'on essaie de cacher la
misère et de faire croire que Paris
c'est une vie parfaite où il fait bon
vivre etc
ils ont demandé au rat de se laver
avant
tu vas voir des rencontres
au lieu d'affronter le problème et
d'aider ces gens qui crèvent la bouche
ouverte dans la rue on veut les éloigner
avant de leur situation encore plus
précaire tout ça pour faire croire que
que Paris est une ville magique non
c'est pas le cas c'est infestédra c'est
un festin de poubelle il y a des SDF qui
sont pas pris en charge il faut arrêter
croire que Emilie de Paris c'est la
vraie vie Paris c'est dégueulasse et il
faut qu'ils assument au lieu de cacher
comme ça que c'est que la signature
l'obtention des JO c'est sa date pas
d'hier donc on avait le temps de régler
le problème et trouver des solutions de
créer des centres d'hébergement etc donc
là on va partir en urgence on va les
mettre dans des dans des centres
transitoires pour ensuite une fois ces
centres transitoires pendant quelques
jours les emmener peut-être dans des
hôtels ou autre ces associations qui
vont s'en occuper les mairies disent
mais nous on va gérer
elle a fait vraiment
sur les sans-abris en disant voilà
on va dire il manque des logements
sociaux
etc etc elle avait même dit Hollande
aussi
un moment donné qu'elle allait créer des
espèces de Bul voilà pour non mais c'est
dingue et en fait elle a rien fait dans
Paris donc depuis 2018 elle parle des
sans-abris elle dit valent pas régler le
problème non mais finalement il s'est
rien passé et là elle se rend compte que
voilà 2024 arrive et qu'il faut planquer
tout le monde c'est n'importe quoi c'est
n'importe quoi oui madame non je disais
que c'est même pire que ça c'est que en
fait par exemple près de Rennes ils vont
faire un centre et c'est qu'on ça va
être construit sur un terrain où il y a
de l'hydrocarbure des métaux lourds donc
en plus c'est carrément de leur santé et
on fait le ménage quoi voilà
aujourd'hui les sans-abris quand ils
sont sous les rocade
aujourd'hui qu'il y a des sensations
maltraités à Paris donc nous on se
bouche le nez parce qu'on va les envoyer
en Bretagne mais sauf qu'en Bretagne on
leur offre éventuellement une formation
en leur permet d'avoir des papiers parce
qu'il y en a beaucoup qui sont ou sans
papier
des hôtels c'est pas 2024 le problème
des 100 d'abris c'est pas 2020 c'est pas
et on essaie d'arrêter les 100 abris en
laissant les sous ce que je demande
rien des gens qui travaillent on va leur
dire c'est bon les deux là ce que je
demanderai mon ce que je t'explique ma
chérie il se dit à chaque fois c'est
complètement dingue
quand il y a eu le covid comment on a
trouvé des milliards il y a eu la guerre
en Ukraine on a trouvé des milliards là
il y a les JO on va trouver des
milliards donc en fait
pourquoi on les trouve pas avant c'est
milliards
l'occasion qui fait la ronde c'est
l'occasion qui fait de la ronde il y a
des gens qui travaillent il y a des gens
il y a des drogués qui veulent pas à se
soigner voilà sous emprise avec des
whisky demande c'est comment ça se fait
qu'on trouve l'oseille on n'arrête pas
d'en parler ici alors vous voulez quoi
vous voulez qu'il soit logé à Paris vous
voulez qu'on les envoie s'ils ont pas le
droit d'être là quelque part et tu leur
envoies dans le pays
on les envoie en Bretagne ils vont voir
la mer
moi si tu me demandes de payer des
impôts parce que je gagne de l'argent je
paye un max d'impôts je peux pas faire
s'il te plaît je vais pas invité 5100
abris chez moi une question que je fasse
de plus mon ami
par ailleurs c'est même pas c'est même
pas les mérites c'est pas les préfets
c'est les associations qui vont sur le
truc donc on comprend pas pourquoi tout
d'un coup c'est une décision
sont plutôt d'accord
c'est une décision étatique qui est
gérée par des associations les mères
disent mais ça arrive sur nos communes
mais on n'a pas la main dessus donc il
gère à moitié les associations peuvent
prendre en partie mais pas complètement
qu'est-ce qui se passe pour la vie pour
la bouffe parce que certains disent nous
on les prend mais on prend le logement
donc pas la nourriture en compte donc il
va il faut qu'il trouve à manger par
eux-mêmes donc il y a plein de trucs qui
sont pas donc on les laisse
[Rires]
c'est une mesure qui va concerner
essentiellement les migrants et les
études prouve que tous les micros qui
ont été tu te déplaces pendant que tu
parles
c'est la seule personne en fait on
dirait que parfois tu passes par des
chemins ou tu es en Edge en fait tu
passes on a l'impression de me dire là
voilà
tes français tu as pas de boulot toi tu
restes là tu dors bravo excuse-moi les
études là où les migrants sont moins
heureux c'est à Paris parce qu'il y a on
leur donne pas de boulot ils sont feu
rouge ils dorment tous ceux qui ont été
accepté de partir et je vais te dire
trouver une épicerie dans un village ils
sont bien accueillis
la question que se pose vraiment la
question que tu t'es posé c'est comment
on trouve à chaque fois qu'on trouve
l'argent comment on va travailler car
comment on va trouver les endroits pour
les loger
on se retrouve l'argent qu'on trouve
toujours l'argent pour tous les
associations les associations donc les
associations sont complices de ça en
fait
[Rires]
débarrasser la ville de de de SDF parce
que ça les dérange parce que pour
l'image de Paris
elle est en train de non mais moi j'ai
pas de problème
je parle du communiqué de presse de la
Mairie de Paris qui dit voilà on va
gérer aujourd'hui les SDF on va les
envoyer à Rennes dans des centres de
formation etc
qu'est-ce que tu en sais mais tu as vu
la vérité